And finally, great news.
ESPN ass hat Skip Bayless
is no longer with us.
Ugh, he was the best
at being
on the wrong side
of every issue.
- One day, I am predicting,
Johnny Manziel
will become even bigger
in the city of Cleveland
than his buddy
and business partner
LeBron James ever was.
[gentle orchestral music]
Give me Josh Freeman,
who was the 17th pick
in the first round,
over Cam Newton.
Why shouldn't I,
as a white person,
be able to take some pride
in Blake Griffin's rise?
Because he did come
from a white mom.
It is a huge mistake
on the part of Peyton Manning.
He chose the worst
situation to win now.
Tim Tebow is
virtually unstoppable
and maybe even
a starting quarterback
for Bill Belichick.
♪ ♪
- All right,
he's not really dead dead;
he's just moving
to Fox Sports.
So to honor his memory,
I thought we should read some
of his most egregious tweets,
which have since been deleted.
These are the lost tweets
of Skip Bayless.
Here's the first tweet
he ever sent out in 1989
when Twitter
was still in beta phase:
"Michael Jordan is a ball hog.
"He will never win
an NBA Championship
with his style of play."
2006:
"Bin Laden is dead.
That's a wrap
on #IslamicExtremism!"
Well, okay.
Well, when did he send
that tweet out?
Yesterday, all right.